vous n'êtes pas déjà grillé vous a bien
sûr
fait quelqu'un avait oublié son sont
un tube de dans le lit d'un tube ben oui
ah tu attends a fait un truc un tubage à
un tube un tube c'est quoi ce tube un
tube de crème quelque chose
tu bosses tu veux un tube quoique comme
quelques chansons non c'est pas un tube
c'était
[Rires]
mais non on s'en fout et celle en soif
ou pas
voilà bah oui on voulait savoir de quoi
c'est je vous le dis c'est votre
meilleure amie non pas du tout mais
pas du tout est en fait le tube écran
avec derrière cube un oui et bien tu me
basile
exercer
la voiture
le tube est tombé entre entre le
matelas et le matelas et le mur et puis
et puis en fait moi là et puis et qu'en
fait quand même ça les revenus qu'elle
s'est couché
et a dit c'est quoi sa belle si jamais
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
mais
c'était une dame qui veut oublier son
sens du poil c'est fou ça m'arrive donc
ça m'a mis un petit peu dans la merde
c'est alors et c'est tout ou bien tryba
c'est tout c'est déjà énorme excusez-moi
déjà grillé un mec oui j'étais avec un
maître chez lui et sa femme de ménage me
ramène des à faire plier l'avait plié
et dont un string qui ne m'appartenait
pas c'est un peu d'autres qui mettait
des strings non non c'est une taille
assez vu voilà valentine et donc il n'a
pas passé une très bonne soirée abbas et
furent vous avez rompu oui
attention la foulée whissell attendons
qu'ils vous embrouiller d'abord il a
essayé de m'embrouiller et puis
finalement c'est pas j'ai pas digéré
laisse toi moi la normale alors faut il
m'est arrivé la même chose heureusement
j'ai dit que c'est à mon père s'est très
bien passé
s'est passé crème salon père doit bien
moi je les fais ça quoi mais votre père
savait qu'il se comportait très bien
avec sa nana elle était très jalouse
j'avais mis embrasser une serviette en
papier mis dans sa poche avec deux
préservatifs et elle l'a fait une scène
magistrale elle m'a mis ses affaires sur
le paillasson c'est dégueulasse manon
lemay keita salif n'diaye ou versa si la
demoiselle la peau niveau riva g20 très
difficile d'un seul coup ça au rythme de
faire c'est l'horreur sitôt la prochaine
fois tu vois si moi ça m'arrive et je me
fais crier je dirais que c'est isabelle
mourinho
m'a trouvé un bail la cei c'est bon
c'est isabelle est sexy conneries
d'avaler roussel attendait koné non mais
oui ou non mais moi je suis un peu moins
indulgent que vous parce que ça peut
déclencher le grosse crise de jalousie
quand même déjà moi j'ai tendance à être
un peu jaloux tous ces trucs là ce me
méfie énormément en fait vous êtes
premier degré sur tout les sujets oui
les médias qui avait lui c'est énorme et
ça rigolait c'est jean marc jean marc
ayrault non je vous fais tu sais je suis
toujours au loup c'est long mais sans
déconner c'est richard relou c'est un
truc de fou allez on vous a répété un
coup à lécher castaldi c'est mon wii 2
le film mais c'est un truc qui m'est
arrivé chez très amoureuse d'un garçon
et c'était réciproque mais en fait ils
étaient en couple du coup vu que je
savais qu'il faille il devait quitter
sanaa et de la paf est elle elle était
brune moi j'avais les cheveux rouges à
ce moment là donc à chaque fois que je
dormais chez lui je laissais vraiment
des cheveux j'arrête là bas des cheveux
laissés
sur la même chose elle a jamais alors
franchement des cheveux rouges sur sur
un oreiller blanc ça se voit mais là
jamais un expert avait quelque chose oui
mais moi ce qui m'est arrivé c'est le
que le suçon le coup du sort a fait un
arrêt dans le coup la nba où il faut
cacher après et c'est un autre qui m'est
arrivé c'est que c'est en plein coït on
ouvre la porte c'était maman
non en plein qu'ovide me plaît oui
adacore géant plan convives du siège
en plein coït un plein coït quand il ya
des moments qui rentrait non c'est pas
vrai c'est halal a fermé la porte direct
mais bon mal c'est normal pas dire
qu'ici on fait un mais c'est vrai mais
franchement me